is there a script that you're
particularly proud of that you've
written that
um
that did commercially well too
i like basic very much i mean i thought
it was
it was revolutionary at the time when it
came out
um the the uh
and and
and i and i thought it broke a lot of
ground you know and then but also what
happened is you know
is is after the gigantic controversy
paul went back
and shot the first first draft you know
because their people weren't crazed
about it but he shot the first draft
and i've done 18 films
and there's uh
that
that really aren't very well known that
i love
telling lies in america with kevin bacon
and brett rempero i love
music box which is in which is a
sentinel read with them and
with jessica lange i think it's a
terrific movie i've done two movies with
costa gomez
betrayed the music box and i think he's
a wonderful director
um
the uh
the only one that i that i really really
really dislike and i try to get my name
off it
and it was impossible because the money
i've been paid for has nowhere to run
with jean-claude van damme
and the
then and then having said that it's not
sean clarksville
he really wanted to do something the
piece was originally called pals
that richard marquande and i were going
to do together richard and i had done
jagged edge and heart supplier
and richard uh the uh
richard died after heart supply
they brought a new director and john
claude god bless him
did not want this piece to be in the
jean-claude action
he really wanted to do this as a best
drama
and the
studio um really insisted for obvious
reasons that that that it'd be a
better bfd john claude movie
he tried to find it find it but the
director took the
studio side and the movie essentially
got trashed you know so yeah but you
know it's 18 down the line you know so
yeah and it's not a bad percentage
you